how do we as independent filmmakers use
transmedia to elevate our production
pitches or when we're trying to take on
investments or get financing for our
projects how do we use transmedia to
make that more easily accessible so a
question that I got after the first
round of film courage interviews we had
was a lot of people asking me about how
this impacts the the the search for
investment you know independent
filmmakers and event creators are always
looking for money and that's just part
and parcel you have to figure out it pay
the crew you have to figure out how to
you know pay for the sets you have to
buy insurance you have to do all these
things so so money is is is necessary
and so a lot of people were out there
trying to find a private equity
investment into their film and right now
that's that's very difficult when you
talk to any independent filmmakers
they're gonna say the search for
financing is one of the most frustrating
difficult things that that you do as a
film as a filmmaker and and that's why a
lot of people pivot to things like a
Kickstarter or IndieGoGo because they
want to crowdsource that and
unfortunately most you know the vast
majority of things when Kickstarter the
vast majority of films and Kickstarter
don't get funded at all and on average
films on Kickstarter get funded at about
twelve thousand dollars and and if and
if you're a swell thousand dollars on
Kickstarter to make a movie I am rooting
for you and hope you make the greatest
12 thousand dollar movie you've ever
made but if you want to filmmaking to be
your career and you don't want to be you
don't want filmmaking to be your side
hustle then we have to figure out how to
how to get beyond the 12 thousand dollar
movie and so a lot of my focus over the
past year and a half has been working
with independent creators on how to
better position their films for
investment private equity investment and
so because a lot of people a lot of
filmmakers think trends medias for the
back end stuff it's it's after you make
your movie and how to you know how to
promote it or how to extend it or how to
expand it but but I think you need to
one front load your transmedia plan
before you go out to get and
one if you if while you're while you're
writing your script while you're
shopping your script while you're
looking for financing for your script
you could be extending your IP and
building audience the entire time mostly
every writer that I know when they when
they write a script they're hustling
that thing for two three four sometimes
sometimes ten years looking for
investment or trying to get it optioned
and so if during that time that you're
developing hustling shopping whatever
you're doing if during that time the
entire time you're using the tools that
we have available podcast self-published
novels IG TV short stories and what bad
whatever it is if you were just working
the IP and building audience what
happens is when you finally get into the
room with somebody whether it's a
production company for that you're
pitching it to for you if you want an
option or to a private equity investor
you can now have the data and the
analytics of market pre awareness 2.2
because when you walk in the room with
zero brand recognition and zero fans
you're having a different conversation
than somebody that can point say I have
three hundred thousand people who who
love my IP that engage with me and cross
for four or five different channels it's
just a different conversation because
you've you've switched the risk analysis
and that's one thing we talked about one
of the previous videos is is studios
they don't necessarily love great
content they love low risk and the way
the way to skew the risk is to build
audience is just to have audience and if
when you have audience all of a sudden
people feel like you're safer and so
being able to walk into a finance
meeting and point to audience gives you
such a leg up because now you shift that
risk analysis into your into your favor
if you watched Shark Tank the first
thing that that the Sharks asked people
is
how many units have you sold they don't
ask how much money you're looking for
what so how much equity you trying to
give up they ask those questions at the
end the very first question they say is
how many of you sold your one that
you'll me to invest in your toothbrush
how many toothbrushes have you sold why
do they ask that they're asking that to
gauge is this risky or is it not and so
somebody says I've sold 400,000
toothbrushes in the past year
independently is less risky than the
person that sold zero toothbrushes and
in in the entertainment space it's the
same exact thing you you want to be able
to point to the data and the analytics
to be able to prove audience so I think
there's when we're talking about
investment I lean into warren buffett
warren buffett you don't think of them
as somebody like from the film world or
entertainment world but you have to
understand warren buffett's a
businessman who understands investments
and a lot of the people that you go for
investments you target for investment
aren't entertainment people they're
you're rich orthodontist that's in your
neighborhood that just has some money
that you want to be able to go and pitch
this thing - they're not entertainment
people it's the the it's the the person
that made a bunch of money in natural
gas and oil or tech stock they're
business people so you have to
understand what motivates a business
person to be able to to want to invest
into into an opportunity and there's
there I think there's two major
components that you need to have
according to Warren Buffett you need
market pre awareness and you need
scalability and so market free awareness
is being able to show that there are
people that want your product is there
pre awareness in the marketplace we've
seen this in Hollywood for the past 40
years when they say is it based off a
book you know if you if your if your
screenplay is based off of a successful
book it will it will get option faster
than one that's not and and and
anybody's out there shopping will attest
to that that's it that's why the
optioning the the book optioning market
comic book
markets super competitive because people
want to be able to get that market pre
awareness and leverage that into a deal
so you need that market pre awareness
but you also need scalability so what's
the market opportunity in the long term
how big is this not big and how long is
this investment so is it a is it a two
year window of revenue is it a one-year
window of revenue is it a ten-year
window of revenue or a 20 year window of
revenue so how big can we make this
thing it's just a one-off or how big can
we go and so a lot of times we think
about transmedia in the scalability
aspect of it how big can we make it it
can be toys and video games and and TV
and film and all these big things right
that's great because that shows market
opportunity but we also need to use
transmedia
on a smaller scale to be able to shift
the pre awareness game and so if you can
show pre awareness and scalability and
just have a good idea all of a sudden
you have armed yourself with everything
that you need to be able to go into to
an investment meeting and point to to to
you know the the assets that you have as
far as your pitch and so so
understanding how your pre awareness
shifts the risk and how your scalability
increases market opportunity is a really
valuable thing to have and unless you
use a multi-platform trans mediated
model you're not going to get either one
of those things so all that to say we
have to we have to think in a broader
term of what the IP is I think this is
the thing that that Warren Buffett
really Warren Buffett really in a
commoditized market so I talk a lot
about the entertainment industry now
being commoditized and so what I mean by
commoditized is there's a lot of people
making similar products right and if
competition in the marketplace is so
crazy we have zillion things on Netflix
is zillion things on hulu amazon
anything that comes out in the theater
network TV TV cable TV premium TV you
know we have like every its
entertainment is commoditized because
there's so many options that everything
is a little less special and so Warren
Buffett tells business people don't make
investments into products that are
currently in commoditized markets unless
they can shift pre awareness they have
good scalability and they have brand
value if you have brand value all of a
sudden you you can survive in a
commoditize market Warren Buffett also
says that one of the things that help
you help you compete in a in a
commoditized market is volume and
diversification so this is business
principles so Warren Buffett says if
there's if the if the market is
oversaturated and there's there's
there's like a hundred times more stuff
out there then you actually need to
produce more things into the marketplace
right to be able just just to be not
washed away right because we've gone
from a pond to an ocean and if you wanna
make a splash in the ocean you need to
have more of a presence in that ocean so
volume is a strategy within a
commoditize market just general business
principle how does that now equate to
entertainment which is now commoditized
that means now we have to have we have
to have more things more stories into
the marketplace or houston it's is it
how can I make more movies like it takes
a long time to make a movies and I'm
trying to make it like one movie let
alone ten movies exactly you can't make
ten movies simultaneously you put them
all out at the same time it's too hard
too expensive too difficult takes is
it's just that's impossible so now we
have to then use the second component
which is diversification so now we have
our movie that can be one touch point of
the brand maybe the tentpole of the
brand but now we're pushing volume
through diversification so now we're
thinking about what are my digital
assets what what are what's my my social
assets what are my immersive assets arv
are you know how can I have publishing
involved you know what could like how
can I now push volume out on the front
end and the back end to-end diversify
that across mediums and platforms that
now
me to compete in the commoditize market
why are we talking about this because
the businessman that you're pitching to
understands this stuff the biggest one
of the biggest failings of independent
writers and producers and filmmakers is
when they go to pitch they think they're
pitching to themselves that the person
on the other side of the table thinks
like them that if you're filmmaker that
leans into if you're DP and you may love
your color palettes and your your
cinematography and you may have
storyboards and you can talk about
lenses and all these things this is what
you love this is part of your art and
you're going to create the most the your
most beautiful film ever that's great
the odds are the orthodontist or the
investment banker or the the rich lady
in the next seat doesn't understand that
stuff or even if she does she may not be
excited about it what they understand is
business and what they understand is
investment and they understand rate of
return and return on investment they
understand risk they understand volume
they understand diversification they
understand branded ecosystems and all
this sounds like a foreign language I
can imagine all the people watching the
video now and I'm turning into the
Charlie Brown teacher wah wah wah wah
because they say I don't want to think
about that stuff because I'm a writer
I'm a filmmaker
I just want to worry about making my
movie I just wish that person would have
been born 30 years ago like if they were
born not just born 30 years ago like
active in the industry 30 years ago if
they were active in the industry 30
years ago it's a different ballgame now
it's so competitive the world is so
different you have to think about these
other things and so understanding it's
it's empathy it sympathy it's it's
empathetic pitching so if you understand
what concerns that the other person has
then you will be better at pitching your
project you'll be better at positioning
your your your art and your project for
an investment
so what do investors care about what do
investors get excited about what do they
look for and then how do I design my
project and my my proposition in such a
way that alleviates those concerns or
those they hit the touch points that
excite them and so the more you do that
the more successful you'll be at in
getting these investments so if you know
if you know that that investors are
concerned about volume diversification
propre awareness the shifts risk
scalability that increases market
opportunity why would you ever pitch
anything that doesn't have any of that
stuff there and so but the only way
you're going to be able to get that in
an entertainment perspective is using a
multi-platform transmedia super story
approach because again you can't make a
hundred movies now you have to have a
plan to be able to use all these
different assets one really interesting
story to tell you that I think is really
inspirational and really cool and that
makes this whole thing real is there was
a student that that approached me with a
short film idea they were shooting a
great shoot a thesis film to graduate
film school and they needed to raise
$12,000 to to shoot their short film and
he said Houston will you look at my
business plan and I looked at his
business plan and his business plan was
give me $12,000 and I'll make my short
film I'm gonna put it into festivals and
as I win the festivals I'll give you the
prize money until your $12,000 is paid
back that was the plan when I read that
I I applaud this guy for coming up with
that but I'm thinking again like the
like a businessman no way I invest in
that $12,000 into that into that
business plan why it's because one it's
hard to get into festivals and it's even
harder to win I mean that's the thing
that any filmmaker understands it's very
super super competitive so me as an
investor I'm gonna look at that and say
that's risky
like it's very very low a rate of return
I'm probably gonna lose this money and
so I encourage this student I said yeah
I don't think this is gonna go you can
try it I don't think it'll work I think
you would be better off potentially just
asking people for like a go fund me
donation he didn't want to do that he
wanted to actually try to get the
investment and so he identified an
investor in Florida that he wanted to
approach with this opportunity and this
guy owns seven car Lots
and his mom was connected to this guy on
on Facebook they were friends and so he
had just had it again this is not an
entertainment guy
it's a guy that sells cars and so so for
three days we sort of repackaged his
pitch so what we did was we went and we
did a transmedia plan for that and we
went from a product century eccentric
view of the of the of the opportunity
and made an IP centric view of the
opportunity so IP being the larger
intellectual property right and so we
quickly what this what this kid had in
spades was a really cool idea he hid a
cool creative idea and so we for two
days we workshop the idea and we we
developed we developed a podcast we
developed a self-published novel we
developed a concept for a digital comic
book we developed a concept for a
musical EP he knew some people at the
Music School that were that was that he
contacted they said they would create
six songs that extended the story they
would do it will inspect for him and
they had a rev share that they were
gonna do we we sketched out the
self-published novel we sketched out a
feature film and a TV series and we
figured and they all told different
stories within the same story world they
were all connected together in this
really interesting way and they all
worked for one whole big puzzle and so
then the pitch became I want you to
invest in not into my short
I want you to invest into the IP itself
right so now your financial you the
investor our financial partner into my
in my intellectual property so what
we're going to do first is we're going
to take the twelve thousand dollars and
we're going to put it into the short
film because that's what I need to shoot
the short film for but listen we know
that short films probably won't make
money I'll put it in the festivals and
if I win then I'll give you some give
you the prize money but the point of the
short film no longer is driving revenue
primarily its building audience we're
gonna put it into festivals start to
build an audience with the school idea
we're gonna release the podcast that I
can produce myself for free that's gonna
build audience it's going to get
eyeballs we're gonna release the music
which is gonna get a whole different
demographic of people and also build
audience and get and build excitement
and if the music makes any money you
participate in the profit of that I'm
gonna write it write my own novel self
publish it that's gonna be an Amazon
that's gonna build the audience but if
that like through the book sales if that
starts making money you participate the
investor participate in the profit of
that the digital comic books will be up
on the website his his brother was a
illustrator and said he would spec out
one issue for him if when that's a 99
cent download investor will participate
in the profit of that that's also gonna
build audience the plan is then to do
that for two years we're gonna work the
podcast work the novel work the music
there was there was a release window of
like when they ever think it was gonna
be released I'm we're going to work that
for two years
wild the kid writes the feature film
script right as this being developed as
it's being written that all this stuff
is going to be there with after that two
years if everything works out the the
the plan will be will have enough
audience and pre awareness to then start
approaching production companies to
option the script but we're not just
going to be some but an IP that no one's
ever heard of we can point to our brand
awareness and we can point to our
audience that we can point to our
community fans and so now we have at
least a
Hunter's chance to be able to sell the
feature if the feature sells you the
investor participate in the profit of
that and then you know listen this is
pie in the sky long-term thinking if the
film does well and we sort of have this
like cult success on our hands its indie
success maybe then we can sell it as a
TV series and and if that goes you
participate in the profit of that and so
now it's a it's a ten year plan rather
than just a short full plan but you can
see immediately how that just became a
whole other thing like that from an
investment perspective the investor
looks at that completely differently it
seems it seems like a bigger opportunity
it seems it seems reasonable and and
this guy sells car Lots so we went oh he
has cars 7 car Lots he sells cars we
went and put the car lot in every story
because what does the car lock guy care
about most discs selling cars cares
about his car Lots so we made it a
location in the story world and we make
sure it was in every story so we he
works that up into a pitch deck the
whole plant is there you know it works
the he does the business the business
the business plan runs the numbers for
all the stuff and then goes off to
Florida a couple weeks later gives me a
call after he gets there he was been
there a couple days gives me call and
says houston i got my investment i said
you got your twelve thousand dollar
investment it's amazing he said no I
didn't get a twelve thousand dollar
investment I got a two hundred and
thirty thousand dollar investment I said
really like how did you get a two
hundred thirty thousand dollar
investment he said well I just sat down
with this guy and I laid all this stuff
out and this guy looked at me and said
you know what this makes business sense
and he says I don't know anything about
entertainment but this makes business
sense and then the guy said he said do
you know how much money I waste in
marketing across my car Lots every year
and and he said I he said he wastes
about 40% of his marketing budget just
on Billboard's no one ever sees
commercials no one ever watches and he
said because this makes business sense
and because you have the car lot in here
I can take 10% of my marketing budget
across all seven of my Lots and out
just invest it into the IP because if it
doesn't work I was gonna waste the money
anyway but if it does work all of a
sudden the business model seems
interesting enough to where this could
be a good long-term investment for me
and all of a sudden this could be huge
for me and my brand and in the fact that
the car Lots in there may it will
probably do little market my car lots
better than then my regular crappy
used-car lot
commercials will is that people will
come to my car lot just because it's
like a movie location and it taps into
all of the thing and so all of a sudden
repositioning that that project from a
product centric point of view to an IP
point of view IP perspective that one
had a plan of how do you build pre
awareness that shifts the risk but then
also how do you increase scalability on
the back end that increases your market
opportunity and how do you make it make
business sense for the person across the
table now if if that didn't work and he
was going to an orthodontist who has
money in the next he will probably
have to change that
take the car let out do something else
right and so so you have to be you you
probably not just gonna have one pitch
for for your IP you you need to design
it for the person to whom you're
pitching make it a tailored suit rather
than the suit they have to fit in and so
all of a sudden this this from an
independent perspective this makes an
independent private equity venture a
hundred times more interesting and more
valuable than just the person that has
the one script or the one movie idea or
the one short film or whatever it is so
again do you have to figure it out a
little bit more of course right but but
I think a problem is there's a lot of
people that want to achieve what other
people have without doing the same
amount of work that other people do and
so yeah like we just we live in a time
that independent creators have to do
more work than ever before to be able to
survive in a commodity
- oversaturated entertainment market but
at the same time we're blessed to live
in a time where we have so many tools
that my parents my grandparents my
great-grandparents never had right so
it's so it swings both ways you just
have to get out of that that same
mindset see the opportunities all of a
sudden went to be if you're able to
implement those opportunities your
investment pitch come it's a completely
different conversation
you